come in entering his fourth season in
the purple and gold his 19th season
overall 35
367 points but i don't care about that
because he is an nfl analyst
now lebron
james man that was fun i got uh welcome
by the way lebron welcome welcome
i appreciate it oh that was a hell of an
introduction chris okay i appreciate
that man you know i get excited for
these things and i got to tell you
lebron ali and i true story we're on the
phone last night we're talking media day
we're going through our questions and
then you came on espn2 with with the
manning brothers we literally hung up on
each other we never spoke again
i loved it i got my one question before
we get into basketball my one question
peyton manning puts you on the spot man
there's only like two seconds left and
he says what play are they running you
were smooth under fire you said hand off
to zeke touchdown bang peyton erupted
how fun was that moment
no it was very fun man uh i'm a big time
football guy so
i was just actually just reading the
defense like i do in basketball i seen
that the eagles only had three uh
defensive linemen uh their linebackers
was playing deep and uh they had just
ran the uh the half back draw to play
before and got a bunch of yards so i
felt like they'd go right back to it
because uh philly didn't change their
defense so i was able to call it on the
spot and
you know i appreciate mike mccarthy and
the offensive coordinator
making me look good making me look good
uh ali and i's favorite part is when
peyton basically scolded eli and said
lebron is the system all right don't ask
that question
i was trying to do it
was like let's keep it right right right
you know that's what happened that's the
big brother hey that's the big brother
for you
listen lebron now you're entering your
19th season i think at this point you
know you're the you're the league's
third time uh all-time leading scorer
most guys are kind of you know sailing
off into the sunset that just doesn't
seem to be your style so i will ask you
this i think i ask you every year what's
your excitement level heading into this
training camp you're 19.
i'm super excited um
you know i know for sure that i won't be
able to sleep tonight just going into
the first day of practice tomorrow
um i love the group that we put together
this summer
and uh you know i love the growth of the
guys that's coming back
and uh i i can't wait i mean this is
gonna be a uh
i can feel it um i can feel the energy
you know i can feel the aura
um and it's all about now just putting
in the work it's all about trusting you
know the process working towards the the
process every single day
but uh i love this i love the beginning
i love what we have to start and uh
looking forward to getting to work
you know uh lebron
even as a young player i remember you
knowing how to understand
uh the process of putting together
the missing pieces or adding on players
and you know over your career you've
been very successful at that talk about
the additions
and
what what what's been made this year the
players that are coming in
and and what you see uh their value
added and how that's going to play out
in in your opinion
uh well i mean uh i think it's gonna be
grand for our team i mean we've added uh
a lot of shot making we've added some
dynamic players that could do multiple
things without with the ball in their
hands without the ball in their hands we
added some length um some vertical
spacing you know that we lost last year
you know bringing back dwight um and
deandre um you know and you know the
dynamic
and russ and what he brings to the team
just his energy his pace his competitive
nature uh you know we brought back uh
you know championship players you know
trevor ariza you know bring back doe um
and then just guys unsung guys that you
know a lot of people i don't know if
they know about but uh they're gonna be
bringing so much to our team you know
and cam bazemore kendrick nunn you know
what they bring to the table is is
ridiculous wayne ellington's shot
ability um and and let me not forget uh
you know the growth once again another
summer for taylor horton tucker thc you
know i'm excited about him um and what
he's going to bring to our team so
we're dynamic we have the ability to do
a lot of different things out on the
floor
um you know but it's up to us to put the
time in
which we will you know i'ma hold this
team accountable they're gonna hold me
accountable so i'm not worried about
that lebron starting at the top when it
comes
to you guys as players there's a lot of
talk about you and russell and right
rightfully so uh we're gonna get into
the fit of the three of you as stars in
just a minute but there's also another
guy named anthony davis it just seems
like some people have forgot about him
what does in your mind
rejuvenated anthony davis look like
uh you know a lot of people go through
the summer and they like to uh you know
post their workouts and post their
training and post everything that
they're doing
uh if it was one guy
that you did not see this summer until
he got married last week it was anthony
davis
and uh but i knew everything that he was
doing
um you know putting in the work
um you know both in the weight room and
also on the court um and he's determined
to uh it's not even about proving people
wrong it's about
you know proving himself right you know
because you know what he could bring to
the table
and uh you know he's one of the best
players that we have in this league and
i'm looking forward to a very angry uh
anthony davis the anthony davis that i'm
looking forward to seeing this year it
would be the equivalent of if the green
bay packers lost on a sunday you know
how angry it would be so
uh i'm looking forward to that one did
you know he could sing like that
lebron uh i i did i actually did um
you know uh but you know you get a
little excitement you know you know your
family and friends is there
mixed with a little you know alcohol you
can do a lot of things that you do yeah
we get brave you get brave under those
circumstances yeah you get real brave
that liquid courage that's what that is
lebron the addition of uh russell as
well as ali was just mentioning a lot of
talk since the trade has been about
the fit with unad the sacrifices that
everyone will have to make how do you
envision this looking with you three on
the court
uh for one i've i've heard it before um
you know when i when i decided to go to
miami the first thing they said was
lebron and d-wade don't mix there's no
way they could play together they too
ball dominant um you know they can't
shoot the ball from the uh from the
perimeter um it's not going to work
they're two similar players
so i mean we know what happened with
that um you know so uh you know you make
it work you figure it out i know what
russ brings to the table he know what i
bring to the table and when you got a
unicorn like a.d you know he fits into
anything i mean they said that you know
i mean ad wouldn't work when we traded
for him so
um you know i i don't really get it
caught up in the narrative at this point
that's all part of uh just trying to
sell tabloids i'm 19 years in this thing
so i know what it's all about so the
game is one and between between the four
lines and there's not one on paper you
know it's not one and the news clippings
on you know the bottom ticker is one in
between these four lines 94 feet so you
know we got a job to do and we'll do it
lebron you look wonderful in your number
six we appreciate you being ready on
that headset right when we came on air
we're gonna let you go because you have
a lot to do today but always love
spending time with you thank you so much
i appreciate it chris alley big game
james love you guys i'll talk to you
soon all right lebron lebron we'll be
james
and look at that entering his 19th
season the league's third all-time
leading scorer behind cap
karl malone and then behind him of
course late great kobe bryant and
michael jordan
le